[Music]
this morning we're taking the tenure
challenge in our reporters notebook a
lot can happen in a decade we compile
and lose memories and gains gain lines
on our face with each new candle on the
birthday cake but when we think about
our lives at that gate ago there's more
to ponder than simply how we used to
look and what we used to wear like many
of you I spent some time this week in
January of 2009 I took the ten year
challenge I posted a picture from 10
years ago and one from more recently not
really a challenge to post pictures of
yourself on social media
you don't need grappling hooks it's not
that hard to climb mount vanity a lot
has changed in those 10 years the
t-shirt I'm wearing is for a band that
no longer exists the girl I'm holding my
daughter was recently mistaken for my
wife social media usually distracts us
with the immediate but this challenge
injects perspective my notebooks say
that 10 years ago I was covering the
inauguration of the first African
American president a snapshot of January
18 2009 shows that the most popular
story on the internet said Republicans
were giving the new guy the benefit of
the doubt President Bush called Obama's
inauguration a moment of hope and pride
and that snapshot of good relations in
Washington looks nothing like today
though the story also quoted a
congressman from Iowa who said Obama's
inauguration meant al Qaeda would be
dancing in the streets in greater
numbers than they did on September 11
that Congressman Steve King was
sanctioned this week by his Republican
colleagues for questioning why terms
like white supremacists should be
considered offensive Steve King did not
pass the real 10-year challenge which is
will my actions and words today
hold up ten years from now and if not
and my purchasing wisdom that will guide
the next 10 years that's the challenge I
see in those pictures and it's the
challenge for Washington too if you took
a snapshot of Washington today it would
be grim we hope that the
in ten years we'll be brighter and that
leaders will focus on that picture and
not the next tweet or photo op otherwise
they will have failed their challenge
what a nice perspective John because
it's so much more than how you look
really how you think and how you move in
the world and I hope I'll be here for
the next two years you and me both